are you concerned that if this Court
this year were to say that there is a
constitutional right for same-sex
couples to marry that there are parts of
the country that would not be able to
accept or would not accept that decision
I think it's doubtful that it wouldn't
accept it the change in people's
attitudes on that issue has been
enormous in recent years people have
have said this is the way I am and
others looked around and we discovered
it's our next-door neighbor we're very
fond of them or it's our child's best
friend or even our child I think that as
more and more people came out and said
this is who I am and the rest of us who
recognized that they are one of us that
there there was a familiarity with
people it didn't exist in the beginning
when the race problem was on the front
burner because we lived in segregated
communities and it was truly a we they
kind of thing it's not so I think the
gay rights movement so I think it would
not take it would not take a large
adjustment and of course we shouldn't
speak much more about this subject
because one way or another it will be
decided before we leave town in June